salut trade à l'ancienne histoire à la
Belle-Mare c'est reparti ou plutôt ça
continue dans ce nouvel épisode je vais
vous emmener en 1912 à Dijon là-bas nous
allons retrouver une petite épicerie qui
est tenue par Armand Lambert et sa femme
céleste Lambert armoire céleste donc un
seul désir dans leur vie c'est d'acheter
le magasin qui à côté de chez eux qui
est une fromagerie j'ai bien conscience
que pour l'instant l'histoire ne démarre
pas sur les chapeaux de roues mais vous
allez voir Armand à 45 ans il a le doûté
il a pas vraiment le physique d'une
gravure de mode c'est pas pour ça qu'on
vient chez lui d'ailleurs on vient chez
lui parce que il est très gentil très
serviable peut-être trop gentil trop
serviable vous savez ce genre de vendeur
qui en fait toujours un peu trop qui
rigole trop fort qui fait les
compliments un peu mielleux sa femme
elle de son côté est beaucoup plus
timide plus réservée et justement la
timidité de sa femme fait qu'elle
regrette déjà d'avoir accepté le plan
que son mari a concocté pour qu'il
puisse gagner E2 plus d'argent c'est un
plan machiavélique précis quasiment
parfait qui va bien se passer d'ailleurs
mais qui se retourner contre eux tout en
se basant bien quand même c'est dur à
comprendre vous allez voir c'est
incroyable je pense que n'ayons jamais
imaginé que ça pouvait se passer comme
ça Armand va ouvrir le magasin et voici
le plan qu'il a concocté lors d'un
moment d'affluence dans le magasin quand
il y aura des clients et des clients il
va monter le long d'une échelle pour
accéder aux étagères là il fera semblant
de tomber enfin il tombera réellement
mais provoquera cette accident une fois
que tout le monde sera autour de lui ici
mullera le fait de ne plus pouvoir
marcher pour toucher l'argent de
l'assurance c'est plutôt un plan banal
somme toute mais c'est assez bien
concocté surtout que en 1912 on n'a pas
les mêmes moyens scientifiques
qu'aujourd'hui pour déterminer si oui ou
non si vraiment il a perdu l'usage de
ses jambes sa femme allait clairement
terrifiée par ça les terrifiés du fait
qu'il pourrait se faire mal qui puisse
bouger sincère s'en rendre compte après
dans le futur si jamais ça fonctionne
que les assurances se rendent compte de
cette simulation à la peur aussi tout
simplement de pas être crédible le
moment venu quand on l'interrog fois par
la suite tout simplement quand son mari
sera au sol alors Armand lui dit je veux
des cris et des larmes tu assures il a
pas dit comme ça mais lui la matinée se
passe normalement et une cliente une
habituée d'ailleurs arrive dans
l'épicerie demande du sucre de canne
c'est le bon moment parce qu'il y a
trois quatre autres clients dans
l'épicerie et le sucre de canne se
trouve sur une des étagères la plus
haute donc clairement prends son échelle
monte le long des barreaux arrivé au
dernier barreau il fait semblant de
perdre l'équilibre il tombe sur le sol
lourdement comme prévu tous les clients
se précipitent sur lui pour savoir ce
qui se passe pour l'aider pour qu'il
puisse se relever parce que la chute
n'est pas très très haute somme toute
mais lui il hurle de douleur et une
bouche pas ses jambes et il hurle à la
mort quoi il a mal il a très très mal ça
se voit il appelle sa femme sa femme
rejoint les clients elle est terrifiée
elle est en panique et puis en réalité
sa timidité fait que sa réaction
émotionnelle très gênée confuse rouge
passe pour de la sincérité sur elle
voyant son mari avoir très très mal un
client sort de l'épicerie et court pour
aller chercher le médecin on est en 1912
on n'a pas de téléphone portable sur soi
à portée de main le médecin arrive une
quinzaine de minutes après il est
accompagné de de policiers d'agents qui
vont emmener Armand sur un brancard sur
une Sylvia pour emmener directement à
l'hôpital et à l'hôpital ça tourne en
rond pendant des jours et des jours les
médecins ne comprennent pas il y a rien
de cassé il y a quelques contusions mais
bon c'est rien de très grave non plus
ils arrivent pas à comprendre ce qu'il
aille pourquoi il arrive plus à bouger
ses jambes une conclusion tombe un
diagnostic il s'agirait d'un choc
nerveux et c'est pas idiot le choc
nerveux à cette époque en 1912 ça
pourrait expliquer ça puisque encore une
fois on ne voit rien de physiologique et
pourtant les gens me sont littéralement
sans vie une fois que le diagnostic des
médecins est tombé l'assurance qui est
pas très contente et obligé de payer et
de verser les 100 000 qui lui doivent
exprès on va dire 100.000 euros j'ai
fait la conversion de ce que ça vaudrait
aujourd'hui en 2022 en prenant en compte
l'inflation et en faisant la conversion
des devises évidemment Armand retourne à
la vie normale et retourne à l'épicerie
avec Céleste et il est présent en plus
dans le magasin tous les jours il aide
pas vraiment il fait pas grand-chose il
en fauteuil roulant et tous les soirs
une fois que céleste baisse le rideau de
fer de l'épicerie bah là il se lève d'un
bon pour se dégourdir les jambes pour
marcher un petit peu dans le magasin
parce qu'il en peut plus de rester assis
vous aviez compris il n'a rien que ce
soit bien clair il a même pas une petite
douleur lancinante quelque part et
qu'est-ce qui fait quand il se lève
d'après vous ben il se plaint auprès de
sa femme il se plaint parce que toute la
journée il doit rester assis il doit se
contrôler il doit faire attention à pas
se lever pour pour aider sa femme par
exemple que c'est très long que c'est
fatigant c'est assez amusant d'ailleurs
je me sens en perspective parce que
pendant ce temps là avant ils étaient
deux à travailler dans l'épicerie là il
y a plus que céleste qui travaille donc
ça veut dire que toute la journée comme
magasin est ouvert modèle qui fait tout
mais bon c'est rarement quand même qui
se plaint en fin de journée enfin il y a
pas que des points négatifs 3 mois plus
tard Armand est plutôt joyeux plutôt
heureux il rigole énormément parce que
ils ont touché les 100.000 euros de
l'assurance mais il y a quelque chose
que lui n'avait même pas anticipé dans
son plan machiavélique c'est
l'augmentation de la fréquentation de
l'épicerie parce que oui la clientèle de
l'épicerie à triplé c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a des gens du quartier qui allaient chez
d'autres épiciers qui du coup viennent
pour soutenir ce pauvre homme paralysé
quand même qui a eu un accident il faut
bien l'aider de manière d'une autre
alors on vient faire ses courses chez
lui il y en a qui qui traverse Dijon
quand même pour venir chez lui parce
qu'ils ont entendu parler de cette
histoire donc ils viennent le voir ils
viennent m'aider un petit peu au final
les affaires sont prospères et célestes
d'ailleurs finissent cette journée
épuisée parce qu'elle fait tout donc
trois fois plus qu'avant mais avec une
personne en moins pour l'aider Armand et
céleste compte pas faire ça
éternellement leur plan à une suite et
compte faire ça deux ou trois ans pour
générer assez d'argent
revendre tout leur bien et partir
s'installer dans le sud de la France là
où personne ne les connaît ni d'avant ni
Dave ni d'avant donc Armand pourra vivre
une vie normale après dans le sud je
vous emmène maintenant un an et demi
plus tard on est en 1913 l'épicerie est
toujours active à moins est toujours en
fauteuil céleste s'occupe de tout
magasin et en plus l'épicerie a doublé
sa surface puisqu'ils ont racheté comme
c'était prévu par le plan la fromagerie
d'à côté qui avait fait faillite entre
temps sauf clairement peste de plus en
plus il en peut plus ça fait un an et
demi qui simule le fait de pas pouvoir
marcher ça fait un an et demi que du
coup il a juste des heures un peu libres
le soir quand tout est fermé les rideaux
sont tirés quand personne peut le voir
pour vivre normalement il en a marre il
est hors de lui il en arrive même à
râler auprès sa femme en lui reprochant
que elle elle ne subit pas tout ce qu'il
subit à part que elle encore une fois
elle s'occupe du magasin alors elle
essaye de le rassurer elle lui dit mais
il y en a pas pour longtemps bientôt
un plan sera exécution pour aller dans
le sud tu vois ça fait que 1 an et demi
et lui il lui dit un an et demi c'est
déjà trop j'ai fait des comptes il
faudrait encore trois ans avant qu'on
puisse partir trois ans et 3 ans c'est
deux fois encore ce qui vient de vivre
là ici qu'il en sera pas capable céleste
elle flippe de fou à la peur à la peur
que son mari fasse une bêtise qui se
lève qui finissent en prison que elle
soit la risée du quartier qui fasse
failli derrière je veux dire s'il y a
n'importe quel moment si Armand arrête
la simulation là c'est le ciel qui leur
tombe sur la tête ça l'a perturbe
tellement céleste que ce coup-ci c'est
elle qui va avoir une idée elle c'est
timide à la base va mettre une brique en
plus sur ce plan je vous passe quelques
mois on est en été 1913 et céleste et
Armand San dans un train direction Paris
pour prendre un autre train direction
lourde vous allez deviner la suite ils
veulent faire croire un faux miracle
l'idée c'est que Armand fasse la queue
avec les vrais malades les vrais
handicapés qui l'aille se plonger dans
l'eau et qu'une fois dans l'eau il fasse
semblant de récupérer l'usage de ses
jambes et qu'il crie au miracle c'est
hyper culotté mais c'est tellement
culotté qu'effectivement ça pourrait
marcher en plus ça Armand a améliorer un
petit peu l'idée de base de Céleste et
pour que ça marche faut que ça fasse du
bruit faut vraiment que tout le monde en
parle et en plus si tout le monde en
parle du coup je vais devenir une petite
vedette locale et là c'est pas la
clientèle on va pas la tripler là la
clientèle elle va venir de tout Dijon et
de tous les alentours pour voir l'homme
miraculé c'est pour ça qu'ils vont à
Lourdes seulement en plein été plus
précisément ils arrivent à Gordes le 15
août le moment où c'est le plus blindé
où il y a les plus longues que pour
aller atteindre l'eau miraculeuse
clairement et céleste ont tout prévu ils
savent déjà que à leur retour ils vont
peindre une sainte Vierge sur la
devanture du magasin ils veulent même
changer le nom de l'épicerie Armand
voudrais appeler l'épicerie au miraculée
et qui se trouve que c'est un petit peu
tout moche dit on pourrait l'appeler
Sainte-Bernadette ou quelque chose comme
ça peut-être plus léger bref ils sont en
train de faire la queue entre les
fauteuils entre les brancards la tenter
longue très longue et enfin vient le
tour d'Armand Armand est porté il était
posé dans l'eau il se laisse couler
entièrement jusque au dessus de la tête
avoir de l'eau au-dessus de la tête et
là immédiatement il se lève et regarde
ses jambes il fait mais je marche je
marche et cela
vous imaginez bien sa femme céleste
tombe en larmes elle hurle de joie en
plus aussi bien sur le monde joie que
c'est l'arme sont sincères parce que
elle sait que maintenant tout va
redevenir comme avant donc c'est super
pour elle il y a plein de photographes
qui sont présents ce qui est pas
étonnant dans les périodes de fortes
affluence il y a souvent des reportages
qui couvrent l'événement donc comme le
présenter Armand tout le monde prend des
photos et couvre tout ça Armand enchaîne
les rencontres les serrages de mal les
explications avec les croyants avec les
officiels le soir ils sont par Hôtel ils
ont pris un noter évidemment sur Lourdes
le téléphone sonne c'est l'adjoint au
maire de Dijon qui les appelle parce
qu'il veut organiser leur retour donc il
faut connaître l'horaire du train etc la
date précise de retour pour prévoir une
fanfare à leur arrivée pour couvrir cet
événement on a un miraculé qui arrive de
Lourdes et 40 chez nous à Dijon c'est
clairement le début du succès qu'avait
prévu Armand tout se déroule comme prévu
jusque là quelques jours après le 20
août 1913 il repart ils ont fini leur
affaire à Lourdes ils ont fini de faire
valider ce miracle ils prennent un train
lourd de Paris pour la connexion ensuite
Paris Dijon surtout le trajet il
rediscute encore de comment ils vont
renommer la fameuse épicerie mais tout à
coup coup de frein long très long
strident qui termine par un choc violent
le train vient de rentrer dans un train
de marchandise qui était bloqué sur la
voie
heureusement aucune victime a déplorer
aucun blessé pour l'essentiel des wagons
il y a un wagon qui a pris un peu plus
cher que les autres c'est-à-dire qui a
été un peu malmené mais a priori il y a
pas de dégâts dans ce wagon là sauf dans
un compartiment celui d'Armand et
céleste la glace qui était au-dessus
d'Armand vient de se casser se décrocher
et de tomber littéralement dans les
gendarmes la suite est simple direction
l'hôpital Armand était tombé à
inconscient durant le trajet mais tant
mieux ça lui évite de souffrir à
l'hôpital les médecins font ce qu'ils
ont à faire une fois que tout est réglé
il réveille Armand et il y a une bonne
nouvelle qui l'attend à son réveil il va
vivre tout va bien c'est c'est limite à
double miracle bien d'être miraculé à
lourde là il a eu un accident il y a une
glace qui lui est tombée sur lui etc
cassé etc et tout va bien tout va bien
aller enfin ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
c'est il va vivre il y a une mauvaise
nouvelle avec pour sauver Armand il a
fallu faire très vite et prendre des
décisions très rapides et la meilleure
des décisions à prendre rapidement était
de lui amputer ces deux jambes et c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait voilà comment Armand
est rentré comme il était parti à Dijon
c'est-à-dire en fauteuil roulant sauf
qu'il y est parti en tant que simulateur
et lié à rentrer en tant qu'handicapé
l'épicerie n'a au final pas changé de
nom et pire que ça la clientèle s'est
fait de plus en plus rare dans
l'épicerie pourquoi parce que Armand
c'était plus quelqu'un de gentil de
Jovial je veux dire avant quand il était
en fauteuil il était encore très sympa
et puis là il était toujours triste
terre en train de se plaindre en train
de gémir en permanence ça faisait une
ambiance grisâtre une ambiance un peu
glauque donc les gens étaient un peu mal
à l'aise d'aller là-bas et ils ont
commencé à fuir un peu cette épicerie et
pourtant les habitudes Armand est
céleste quand ils voyaient Armand aussi
mélancolique au départ il disait bah
écoutez dites-vous que c'est c'est comme
avant le miracle juste vous avez pu
remarcher un tout petit peu mais mais
voilà rien n'a changé c'est comme avant
difficile pour rarement et céleste
d'expliquer que non c'est pas vraiment
comme avant non donc l'épicerie a fini
par couler et Armand et céleste sont
partis on ne sait où au final silence
radio plus de nouvelles deux jusqu'en
1940 1940 c'est l'année où est décédé
céleste 15 ans après son mari Armand
était mort 15 ans plus tôt avant son
décès elle avait déjà prévu une
confession publique de son histoire
peut-être aussi pour s'amander un petit
peu d'un péché si elle était croyante
parfois il y a ce genre de choses qui
sont donc ça a été relayé par la presse
et c'est comme ça qu'on sait ce qui
s'est passé à cette époque là et à cette
époque c'est sûr que des personnes se
sont dit ce que vous êtes peut-être en
train de vous dire maintenant de en fait
elle a été punie par un acte divin
c'est-à-dire comme ils ont simulé un
miracle et bien du coup ça s'est
retourné contre eux pour le rendre
réellement handicapé amputé des jeux des
deux jambes ça c'est un biais cognitif
qui s'appelle le biais de corrélation
illusoire quand vous avez deux données
qui fonctionnent ensemble on a
l'impression que du coup il y a un lien
de cause à effet parce que c'est sexy
pour le cerveau de se ça mais évidemment
il y a rien de tout ça en fait c'est la
différence entre la corrélation deux
choses qui pourraient être interprétées
dans leur croisement comme
fonctionnement ensemble et la
conséquence la cause et la conséquence
c'est comme si je vous disais cette
lanterne est très spéciale elle est
magique elle fait en sorte que les
crocodiles ne puissent pas approcher de
moi et jusqu'à preuve du contraire
depuis que je suis dans ces bureaux et
que j'ai cette lampe il y a jamais eu un
seul crocodile il y a pas un effet de
causalité entre la lampe et les
crocodiles c'est juste une corrélation
en fait ce qu'on aurait pu prendre autre
chose voilà c'est important de se le
dire parce que spontanément on trouve ça
très très joyeux pour l'esprit de se
dire ah ouais du coup il a eu ça c'est
un coup du karma etc bon bah c'est
surtout que malheureusement ce train
était arrêté qui a eu l'accident et
qu'il était à la seule place
effectivement où fallait pas être ce
jour-là ne souhaite pas un tel accident
une violence et un tel handicap à qui
que ce soit ils n'ont fait finalement
fait à la base qu'une arnaque à
l'assurance qui est quand même devenue
peu à peu une quelle émotion aussi avec
leurs clients et ça c'est un autre sujet
j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu
merci beaucoup de l'avoir regardé
n'oubliez pas qu'on peut se rencontrer
on peut se voir la fin de mes spectacles
je joue au Palais des Glaces jusqu'au 21
décembre c'est à Paris les mardi
mercredi à 19h30 et en tournée jusqu'à
juin 2023 un petit peu partout en France
Suisse Belgique vous avez les dates qui
s'affichent au tour de moi n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à cette chaîne Youtube et
puis à mes autres réseaux aussi je fais
pas mal en ce moment du contenu sur
insta TikTok et tout c'est pas dur pour
me retrouver c'est Fabien olicard c'est
un arobase c'est très simple j'espère
que ça vous a plu prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt Ciao